The general good experience,
it was a place in Australia and the,
the property owners like the ranch has
called me up and they said you need to
come out and shoot some of the boxes.
Like they'd devastating our lambs and
uh,
I end up going out there and when I was
driving in with a full drive at night
with the high beams on,
I seen this massive big black and white
ball walking between the flock of sheep
with a laminates mouth.
It was these pig and it got a taste for
meat and it happens all the time.
Like so a big bore,
especially a mature animal,
will get a taste for meat in harsh
conditions.
And now just stick the meat after that.
And ended up catching up with these pig
the next morning and shot it with a bow.
It actually attacked me.
The first shot wasn't perfect and it
charged me and I ended up stabbing it to
death.
I was on a slope like this on the
mountain cheese and it was really a
battle like high end up hooking the ball
out of my hand because when he charged
me I'll put an Arrow and shot and just
went down one side and hit one lung and
it just infuriated this bowl and he was
on me and when I was sending him off
with the bow is tasked,
went into the bottom of the bow or the
cam or something like that and rip the
bow out of my hand and I ended up
getting a knife off me and I ended up
stabbing this pig was electronic.
Run me over.
Oh Shit.
How big was it?
It was a big boys like big mountain.
It made eight and bullet like this and
like how many pounds,
you know,
a fucking big 10.
Many pounds.
Probably not 300 hour mountain bullshit.
Get real solid.
Yeah,
probably $200.
Something like that.
And uh,
anyway,
I ended up stabbing this thing to death
and when I ended up cutting it open,
it's whole insides,
like it's whole stomach was like lambs
hawks,
like the feet,
the bottom of the feet where they can't
swallow and skulls and just like little
bits of wool and stuff like that.
He'd just been going around and just
picking these lambs often killing them
and it's a really known occurrence in
Australia and how that if things get
hard,
I would just go just because they,
they just absolutely ruthless.
I would just walk right between the
sheep and just fucking grab a land walk
off of chewed up and Ada.
Yeah.
And how much comes out in the fucking
forest,
Bro.
That's where the next note,
one or swamp thing happened while I was
thinking this,
once they found out that in some plants
some plants contain DNA from salmon
because the salmon were used as
fertilizer by the plant as it
decomposed.
It got into the actual plant itself.
And you can actually somehow or another
through some sort of scientific process
that I'm too stupid to understand.
They can actually detect salmon in the
actual plant itself.
We're close.
So if you were whacking off on that tree
and that tree,
it's everyday.
That's your spot.
You went down to that titty tree and
whacked off on the roots and then like
after a while you did an analysis and
you found your dna in the tree itself.
Imagine.
Oh,
it'd be great,
man.
If it maintains the information of
everything that whacked off on it.
You have a little son made out of wood
one day mom,
your dad.
A kid in our town one time.
Does he go,
I made a son a wooden shirt that I tell
you that a wooden.
Sure.
Yeah.
He made his son a shirt out of plywood
for Christmas.
What do you want a kid to wear it?
Oh,
Yay.
Did.
And I remember I was um,
wait a minute.
Is it a stiff shirt or is it you make it
like little itty bitty tiny pieces of
plywood and weave it all together?
Oh No,
I was pretty stiff and the dad was a um,
like an Elvis impersonator,
you know?
But Dad was an Elvis impersonator at a
casino or did he do it at carnivals this
locally?
Um,
but we didn't even meet him that.
No,
no money really.
I think he's probably an alcoholic,
but he had a,
he had four kids and one of them he
made.
I was going walking home one night and I
heard them in the garage and he's making
like a son,
like a,
like a for Christmas.
Like a wooden shirt,
like a,
you know.
There you go.
Uh,
not as nice.
That one is nice.
Wouldn't shirt?
Yeah.
Can you get sore?
Oh,
but that's a.
like a sculpture.
Yeah.
That's nice.
Can you just get one more?
That's like a,
like if you go over someone's house and
they have a wooden shirt on a hanger,
like and they think that's cute.
Just leave.
Now people are assholes now.
This kid needed it because people used
to this kid.
Is that salmon?
Yeah,
it's a framed wouldn't shirt.
It looks like we used to beat him up
because it was wooden shirt now people
used to beat him up anyway on the bus.
Well the wouldn't share.
It would protect you from a lot of shots
and it helped and it helped.
He didn't wear that,
wouldn't.
Sure.
You better shut the fuck.
I swear to God.
He did not walking around with wood over
his body like that.
Not Today.
That would be.
Yeah.
This was your pads inside of it looked
heavy.
Fuck.
No,
dude.
I think his dad is estee lauder ladies
place,
so to play devil's advocate here so that
that stuff that comes in those dick
pills and you can get from other
steroids,
but it happens to be in those days.
You certainly can.
Yes,
but.
But that is one narrative that you took
clear that you could say,
well it's in these dick pills.
I'm not saying you can't do that.
That's true,
but it's in such a small amount in his
body and it wasn't in his body before
and it wasn't in his body after which
showed that it was only in his body and
extremely small amounts for a small
window amount,
but a small window of time.
So it's not like he had it.
It's not even like this stuff,
which is a metabolite which is showing a
response to the body,
the body responding to the steroids.
And let me ask this,
Joe.
Okay.
Why does no other fighter have any Pico
Pico grant that this pulsating effect
really?
Well,
that's not true.
I mean other tested.
Frank Mir tested positive for something
two years.
Tom Law,
our tests,
but Frank Mir didn't go through the same
steps that Jon Jones did.
He didn't provide them with A.
I forget what the exact there was.
There was something that John did also
that lowered his sentencing reform it.
Yes.
It was cooperating with Usada yeah.
Or,
or agreeing to cooperate with Usada.
Yeah.
That then were just cool with that.
Listen,
I don't even know what that means.
I don't either.
But let me ask you this.
If I agreed to Usada to be an informant,
snitches get stitches.
Correct.
Unless you're John,
that no one can beat you up,
so you're fine.
But the thing is,
is
the only way I can inform you is if
something that have that,
um,
knowing that I know of,
I can inform you of just stuff that's
like,
you lay shit.
That was what I asked Novitsky I was
like,
if you didn't do anything wrong,
and what is he going to offer?
Because if,
unless he took something,
unless you know what you're doing.
Like if I'm an informant for the FBI or
for the feds for cocaine,
I know my cocaine,
right?
We're not going to get joe blow.
That makes my fucking express so we can
get the guy who knows the ins and outs
of cocaine.
That's again,
that's,
I'm like,
all right,
cool.
Before they have a conversation with him
and he says he can provide them with
information with how guys are getting
away with passing truck to.
And how would you know about that?
Unless you're in on that?
No,
I don't either.
I'm just saying again,
to me all of this is a little too much
of a coincidence that the best fighter
on the planet earth has these issues.
The best fight in the planet earth also
ran away from a hit and run.
Smash into a girl,
broke her arm.
He also drove his car into a tree.
He's a reckless person who takes a lot
of chances and he does some,
at least in the past,
has done some things that are not very
wise.
This could fall under that.
It could fall in correct.
Or I began to play devil's advocate.
I'm not accusing them of anything.
Let's play devil's advocate or a guy who
was that Lucy goosey outside the
octagon,
might've taken some performance
enhancing things because that would be
the similar traits.
I,
I think that,
look,
there's certain things that this
administration is doing foreign policy
wise that I think are good.
It makes sense.
There are other things that I think you
just leave you scratching your head.
Um,
but that's like every administration.
I guess my point is we've gotten away
from that ability,
right?
I have conversations.
I go out to dinner with folks that,
you know,
on the,
on the hard left.
And when you talk to them,
they fully believe,
fully believe that president trump is a
Russian puppet,
a winning asset of Putin who is just
doing Putin's bidding.
And they honestly honestly believe that
and nothing is going to shift them off
that position.
When you have a,
you know,
that sort of frame of reference,
you don't have the ability to look at
anything rationally and say,
yeah,
okay,
I like this policy related to China.
It's about time we call them out and say
that you obviously have not been a fair
trading partner.
That's something that every
administration has agreed to but has
never done anything about.
So you would think that everybody will
be to say makes sense.
Yeah,
I like it.
Everybody should be able to say the
immigration system here in the states is
somewhat dysfunctional.
It needs fixing.
Everybody's talked about that and yet
they can't do it because they've got
this,
this mindset that,
that that prevents them from having any
sort of conversation,
any sort of rational discussion that
could lead to some compromise that could
then advance the ball and make the
government more functional.
So
I wasn't even ready for that one.
Charlie Murphy told us a story and it's
animated.
It's on youtube now.
Have you and him coming over your house
in a limousine and us.
It was a lion or a tiger.
Tiger.
Tiger dude.
It is one of the craziest fucking
stories.
I always win.
So for people that don't know,
I got to hang out with you at one of my
shows one time and it was a great.
I had the best time talking about
everything.
What made you think you could get a
tiger?
Like how did that even happen?
Hey,
I'm in.
Um,
I'm.
So,
I'm,
I'm in prison at the time,
so I'm in prison.
I'm talking to my car dealer at the time
and he has,
uh,
he has,
um,
caused the,
belonged to a friend of mine that's both
a friend of ours and he's discussing the
feet other than paying for these cars.
I'm a fellow cars to someone and get
some horses and stuff.
I said,
well,
you can get a hold of
because I had a lot of carbs after I
probably get them off.
You get,
you get cool.
Good Lions,
tigers.
I know this guy got exactly what you do.
Can you give me some tigers?
Yeah.
The Guy told me and the guy from.
Imagine how cool that bad because I had
a bunch of friends because magnet man,
he'd be in the aftermarket for Rami.
You haven't tiger right next to you.
Wow.
Would be cool.
Right after he had gave me some cousins,
man when I came home I had those cups
right there waiting for me.
So you raise them as cups because that's
how.
That's how you work.
Because I would see footage of you like
fucking smacking them around and jumping
on one of your tires and I was like,
Holy Shit.
And I had an incident were bathed that
their mother,
their babies.
Now it never gets.
This is a crazy picture.
You and your underwear with a tiger on
chain.
That is.
That is one of the.
That's you at peak?
Crazy.
Yeah.
And thing.
Going through my mind.
What made me think about my friends and
Mike,
you can get from from the animals and I
think really
going to get from everybody.
Does it though.
Those are one of the things about a with
what's his face from narcos?
Pablo Escobar last.
He got like a fucking
crazy.
Do they all do it.
Once you get like that rich,
you're like,
just get some animals,
animals,
animals.
So people in with the Lions and tigers.
Real common thing that is super rich.
People getting shit.
Jacqueline huddlestone.
That's right.
Michael Jackson.
Language accent.
Everything.
Yeah.
They had like a zoo in his backyard.
He had weird shit.
Like weird birds.
Yeah.
I don't think it may be at a monkey or
something.
He did have weird shit.
Nothing dangerous day before the playboy
mansion.
This is at the end of his career.
That was like whoa.
The thing years ago thumping and it was
pretty awesome.